capital was the defining scarcity of the
industrial age land of the agrarian age
food of the 4-h now attention is the
defining scarcity you know you can't go
back in your life right you can't go
back and change what you paid attention
to yesterday you know a student who is
walks into an exam ill-prepared can't go
back and suddenly prepare a nation that
goes into a global pandemic ill-prepared
can't go back and say oh we should have
done more research on coronaviruses you
just can't do it right so attention is
fundamentally scared and the business
model of some of the biggest
corporations is premised on hogging as
much of that attention as they can
because advertising which is the
fundamental business model of Facebook
and Google is the resale of attention
it's taking as much attention as you can
get and then taking some of it and
selling it to the advertisers and that's
a lot easier to do by giving you faux
outrage and by giving you cheap
emotional things as opposed to saying
hey why don't you go and actually read
this difficult book or why don't you go
and watch this hour-long video that
actually explains something in depth
that's not in the interest in the
interest this here's a quick hit and
here's another quick hit and here's
another quick hit
[Music]
now on yang speaks I sit down with the
incredible Susan Danziger and her
husband Albert banger Susan and Albert
have been friends and mentors of mine
for years
they're both investors entrepreneurs
leaders visionaries they backed my
campaign before anyone else did and we
have a very exciting announcement about
how they're supporting universal basic
income in New York State starting a
little bit later this year thrill to sit
down or to my favorite people in the
world
Susan dancer and Alberta this week on
yang speaks I am so thrilled to welcome
the powerhouse duo Susan Danziger and
Albert banger of freakin universal basic
income Hall of Fame but we at incredible
announcement but Susan thank you for
joining the board of humanity forward
you were gonna make us awesome and
stronger I'm thrilled I think it's a
huge opportunity and really appreciate
your thinking of me because I said thank
you
of course and congratulations to
everything you've done for entrepreneurs
around the worlds last number of years
really you're an awesome role model
you've made a huge difference and then
Albert banger partner at Union Square
Ventures and the author of this
incredible book world after Capitol
which really sums it up Halpert
forecasted need for universal basic
income in part because he thought that
time was going to be the new money and
both Susan and Albert were some of the
original champions of the yank 2020
campaign when we were just like this fly
speck I don't even think we legally
existed I had dinner with Susan and
Albert and said hey I'm gonna run for
president on universal basic income and
they were like yes let's do it so thank
you both for being such incredible
friend
remember that that was a fun dinner yeah
but Michael came up with something but
yang Yang bucks or something yeah yeah
get more yang for your book get more
yang for your buck
well yang bus became a thing so you know
my Michaels like his parents he's also
way ahead of the curve no we made an
announcement I don't know people really
understand it fully so I'd love for you
two to help us Riaan van head set up in
the universal basic income trial we are
going to be giving people $500 a month
for five years in a town called Hudson
New York and it's really the two of you
that helped visualize it and bring it
into the world so I would love to hear
both of you talk about how you came to
universal basic income and then how you
came to want to make this happen in the
town of Hudson in Hudson Valley New York
well so um as you mentioned in the
introduction Susan I've been thinking
about you bi for a long time we're both
in tech and I think if you're in tech
you see what technology can do and you
see what incredible benefits it can have
for Humanity if we set ourselves up in a
way where those benefits can be broadly
distributed where lots and lots of
people can benefit from automation from
machine learning from artificial
intelligence and so we've long been
supporters of ubi and we felt that
supporting opportunities to try it out
at small scale or at large scale it's
something that will help advance
people's understanding of how it works
how it influences people's lives and so
that has led us to this particular
moment and then Susan can talk a little
bit about why Hudson specifically yeah
so we have a well we have a farm where
we are now it's right outside of Hudson
and we are actually launching a Learning
Center in the city of Hudson called the
spark of Hudson and the point of that is
really to inspire people all people in
Hudson Hudson is a really interesting
town
because it's such a diverse one there
are folks that are are quite wealthy and
there folks that are quite middling and
then there are third about a third of
folks who are living at or below the
poverty line and so we figured that if
we can get Hudson right and he lifts up
Hudson up then Hudson can really be a
model for communities around around the
US and the world and you're not just
thinking or talking about it you're
putting your money where your mouth is
and I think we made this announcement
but you've made this incredibly generous
gift to help seed the spark of hudson
and hudson up
what was that amount i just want to make
sure i don't underst eight you were you
know i mean i think our family
foundation of the Utopia foundation and
humanity forward I think we're splitting
this 50/50 here which is great so we are
excited about this partnership with you
and we're we're we're sponsoring twenty
individuals each of whom will receive
five hundred dollars on for a period of
five years so you could do the math and
we're we're yeah and and you know we're
hoping that that this is the first
cohort and that next year we can add
more people to this to this pilot
program so and ideally every year there
are yes that would be a fantastic
outcome so I haven't announced today so
for those of you who don't like math so
twenty people five hundred dollars a
month is ten thousand dollars a month
times 12 months $120,000 a year times
five years and six hundred thousand
dollars so Susan and Albert are putting
up an incredible three hundred thousand
dollars humanity forward is matching
that so we're up to six hundred thousand
and here's what you don't know that I'm
about to share with you both that the
NBA player JJ reddick has decided to
contribute seventy five thousand dollars
in additional capital towards the Hudson
trial oh that's fantastic
so we can make use of that die there
expand the pool of people's lately or
invest in some of the monitoring that
we'll be doing so thank you JJ reddick
that's great how wonderful all right
Thank You JJ
if you have a new favorite NBA player
Susan at Alberta a player before that
[Music]
okay this episode of Yanks Peaks is
brought to you by outer known and I can
comfortably say this is one of the most
comfortable clothing brands I've ever
owned and I think you agree Andrew yeah
that they're they feel great they look
great you know that they were not made
by like miserable Bangladeshi kids who
are getting their knuckles broken or
whatever like that they're made in the
right way and a sustainable fashion so
you feel good about them yeah like I I
love my I don't know enclose I got to
say like they sent them some over and I
was like ooh and then I bought some with
this discount code I'm about to give you
all now I've been enjoying it it's made
by Kelly Slater you know what it is
Kelly Slater I was like an 11-time world
champion surfer like I feel cooler in
these clothes because I feel like a
little bit more of a surfer with ya
would make me a total poser because I
can't surf worth a damn but it makes me
feel a little bit more like professional
surfer you could more like you could
surf yeah and that no one would just
like you know like yell you off the
beach or something so go to Erin own
calm today and enter my code yang at
checkout get 25% off your full price
order that's outturn own calm oh you ter
que ando wnd.com and use my code yang at
checkout for 25% off check them out
today I don't own comm don't forget
promo code yang and yeah enjoy your new
clothes worth it worth it
[Music]
so you're you're leading the way and
they're we're thrilled to be working
with you on this this is an incredible
project and it's the longest time trial
or the universal basic income trial I
believe in the u.s. that's currently
planned or ongoing so you want to talk
about why you committed to five years
initially go ahead
well a big part of what we believe ubi
makes possible is for people to really
invest in themselves and to unfold their
true potential we believe everybody has
amazing potential and that sometimes
takes time you know it may take some
time to work through past problems
before you can start to focus on the
future and then focusing on the future
may take a few iterations and so we
really want people to feel like they
have the support for a meaningful period
of time right um you know just riffing
off what you said it'll allow people to
take risks and that's something that is
so critical for us as entrepreneurs as
you you can appreciate that takes time
to build a business it takes time to you
know as Albert said you know if you've
got folks at home that need to be taken
care of
it'll allow you to do that and if you're
talking about just a year which is what
a lot of these pilots do it really
doesn't afford people the freedom to be
able to maybe stop that you know job at
McDonald's they may have or you know
take risks and start something new
there's an interesting statistic which
is that much as we talk about
entrepreneurship all the time we tend to
talk about tech entrepreneurship but if
you look at entrepreneurship more
broadly meaning people who start let's
say a corner deli or who start a daycare
center or who start any kind of small
business that's actually way down in the
u.s. over the last decade plus yeah and
so that's a real problem because that's
where a lot of communities jobs are
that's where the jobs are and it's where
the life
a lot of communities so for all of those
reasons we think going longer it's
better well I'm a huge fan of a long
time horizon for all those reasons that
you just described where a year's pretty
quick and if you think about in the
context of a business you both know this
that you have to be thinking three to
five years for your business to have any
kind of chance and I also could not
agree more that we talk way too much
about tech tech tech the vast majority
of businesses are just the nail salons
or the food truck or the district sole
proprietorship really I know the vast
majority of businesses are sole
proprietorships where it's just a person
who's how machine go up and said look I
can offer this to my community and those
the kinds of opportunities we need to
make more accessible and realistic to
people rather than imagining that
everyone's going to join some startup
the way it's defined by the press yeah
but but in addition to startups I think
there's a whole swath of folks who are
caretakers who you know this will give
them the opportunity to to stay home
with the kids or take care of an elderly
parent and not have to worry about about
you know about working the jobs I mean
there's you know this is actually the
one of the first opportunities people
have to be paid for being a stay-at-home
mom or dad right and that I think is a
huge huge freedom and something that
that I think truly isn't valued here I
think there was a study that recently
came out that said that if every woman
caretaker were paid last year then they
would have been paid I think it was 1.5
trillion dollars and that's how much
that's how many hours people put it on
baby unpaid work yeah exactly yeah I'm
sure like if you were to properly value
it it'd be several times higher and I
mean you you to have raised some
incredible kids I can vouch for the fact
that you know they should be very proud
your children are considered
really older than mine in Evelyn's but I
said all the time on the trail that
Evelyn's working much harder than I am
you know and the hours are longer the
rest of it like I was doing something
easy like brother president and you can
frame it out either as like this massive
undervalued work which like you said
Susan Levine the trillions of dollars or
reverse you could say is this hidden tax
women because they are in these roles
more often and it's taking away from
their capacities to do work that the
market does recognize but either way you
look at it to me
universal basic income is a huge step
forward towards valuing the real work
that's going on in our homes and towns
every day right and it also gives women
the freedom not just to stay home but
also to be able to say leave
relationships that could be potentially
abusive or they may decide not to move
in with the boy for their boyfriend so
early they may not get you know married
so young I don't know if you know this
Andrew but I did a survey I guess it was
a couple years back and I asked people
that if if they were given $1,000 if
they if they knew as a teenager that
they'd be given $1,000 a month for the
rest of their life how would their life
how would their life have changed and
what was fascinating is that people had
just talked about exactly what we were
talking about they would have started
businesses or started as as a sooner
they would have left relationships not
moved in so early with their boyfriends
not have not they would have stayed home
with the kids or taken care of their
terminally ill mothers you know so all
of the things that we're talking about
really kind of bore out when we
conducted the survey and it's also clear
we would have more artists and
scientists and field lawyers this is
true yeah I mean it's really also in the
numbers does not surprise me at all yeah
I mean there were you know time and time
again people said that they had they
used to have a passion for being
musicians or artists and and they left
those professions I'm in order where
their passions in order to become the
practical lawyers and bankers and
engineers so I think we lost a lot of
lot of talent that
Susan you and I have this in common
we're we're both reformed or refugees
from the law practice but I made the
mistake of going to like a law school
reunion I went because I was running for
office and I was trying to raise money I
was like who's a lawyers I should
know better like these get some money it
was really days of the campaign I'm
saying but I went and I gotta say that
was one miserable group of human beings
like I got there but it's like this is
like an anti brochure portrait yeah it's
the golden handcuffs right the golden
handcuffs where people leave people
think that they can't leave because
they're tied to the to the money that
they're earning yeah so they had
aspirations coming in because you know
we were in school as relatively young
people and they showed up relatively
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed and you
know had aspirations but I did not
surprise me at all that there are a lot
of people who would have chosen another
path if if they do they had some kind of
financial flexibility well one other
point that I think rarely gets mentioned
about you bi but I think is incredibly
important is you know in the u.s. a lot
of people cannot properly participate a
democracy because they are you know
holding down two jobs or because they
live very precarious lives where they
are worried that if they lose the one
job they have that they can't afford
their homes they can't afford food and
so democracy is more than just voting it
it's civic engagement it's being up on
what politicians are doing and saying
and and understanding the issues being
involved locally so this law office
running for office
there's tons of aspects of democracy
that a lot of people I think in the u.s.
are presently precluded from and
sometimes people look at UVI and they
say oh it's just paying people off but I
think they completely underestimate how
much freedom it would give people to
engage in democracy in a way that they
aren't or can't today well similarly I
think that you know there people can
also start volunteering more doing
community work you know it's all
kind of tied together that they have the
time and the money to be able to do
those kinds of work work on the
environment I could not agree more on
both fronts and I'll tell you there are
so many people that are checked out of
our political processes and our
democracy because they don't think it's
gonna change anything significant about
their lives they don't think politics is
for people like them this have their
heads down they think it's all nonsense
and in a way you don't blame them in a
way you're just like yeah I get it
because if you try and engage
politically it's very stressful
sometimes very negative and then you we
make it way too hard to vote who did way
too hard to do a lot of things and so a
lot of people are like I'm just gonna
going to ignore it and universal basic
income can help with that it can help
give you the ability to volunteer in
your community and you talk about the
exploitation of women and the choices
that they make the person I always think
of is the waitress at the diner who's
getting harassed by their boss and if
they had some degree of financial
security they could just be like you
know screw you like you know
need to deal with this and then they
leave and they know they're they can
actually take a week or two to find like
another job that will help keep a roof
over their heads but right now there are
so many of those people who just have to
grin and bear it and there's like this
power dynamic so it's in the workplace
it's in relationships oh one of the
bookie men actually that scared people
away from universal basic income in the
sixties and seventies when they were
doing trials was there was this false
data point that it increased divorce
rates oh no people got into bed at
income that like all I did you know they
would need to stay married which you
know really well the data it turns out
was did not say that but like it's quite
interesting because you think well like
is that necessarily bad if there were
let's say women who didn't feel like
they needed some jerk no it's absolutely
right I mean it's it's a huge amount of
freedom to be able to leave your job to
leave your relationship and
relationships I mean it's just it's what
we all wish for and it's right there
it changes the the bargaining position
fundamentally yeah yeah well one thing
you referenced is a
the composition of Hudson as a town I
believe it's nineteen percent black is
that right there's like a percentage
sounds about right yeah that's right
that's right it's very um as Susan said
it's very demographically diverse now
that was one thing that excited us and
you saw the town that it was diverse in
terms of race and economics where there
are some people that are as you say
almost a third at the poverty line or
below and it's a small enough place
where this this ubi trial I think is
going to be like a massive deal in this
town I don't know whether people have
already been reaching out to spark up
Hudson or Hudson up and what that
process looks like when do we think that
the first monies will start going out to
folks I'm sure there's a lot of need
right now yeah but we're targeting the
middle of October um with maybe slipping
into November but that's what we're
targeting I think one thing that might
be important to mention also is that
we're very fortunate that we have the
support of many community members and
that we also have the support of mayor
Kamal Johnson who you know was recently
elected and who grew up in Hudson and he
is very excited about this also and has
has given us the support to to reach
other others in the community and to
throw his you know um support behind it
so that he's the first black mayor of
Hudson and has been a terrific champion
of ours and the reason that it's taking
taking a little bit of time right now
before the first monies or dispersed is
we're really make trying to make this a
community driven process in terms of how
this election and eligibility criteria
are are put forth so we're really we're
going from community members community
member and organizations and really
talking about the project educating
people and getting their feedback as far
as how it should exactly run yeah and
making sure that people fully understand
what the idea is behind it are so that
when we do launch there isn't a lot of
weird mystery or rumors or other things
that can easily happen with a project
like this we have to get kemal as part
of that new mayor's for you
a group he could joined be like that
matter absolutely I think he would be
thrilled to do that yeah yeah it's I
mean it's incredible a group of people I
don't know if you've met Michael Tubbs
I'm sure you would have at some point
the universal basic income community is
not as vast as what one might imagine
but yeah that come come alls gonna make
a great fit I'm sure Albert one thing
you said to me early on in the campaign
is actually pre campaign but you said
something like the Swiss had to run
referendum on women's right to vote 16
times before it passed or something
along those lines
yeah and you're you and you made that
comparison because you were like we
should start running out ubi now with
the thought that it might take more than
one try and I remember hearing this and
I just loved the the long-term thinking
you had where it wasn't like hey is
Andrew yang going to be in the White
House it was more like hey let's let's
get the first rutted because it might
take multiple tries yeah it might be
worth zooming out for a moment you know
the this ubi isn't a panacea it is one
ingredient in a larger transition and
what is that launch a transition it's
the transition out of the Industrial Age
so the biggest mistake that politicians
in many countries not just the US have
been making for probably the last 10
maybe the last 20 years is to treat
digital technology and computers as if
it was just an extension of the
Industrial Age this transition that
we're going through is as profound as
when we went from being fortress to
agrarian society and then from agrarian
society to industrial society and so
those transitions took long periods of
time and they were multi-generational
projects and they require it the
wholesale reinvention of how people live
and so
ubi is super important it's a
cornerstone but it's not the only thing
that we need to think about when we talk
about how we get past the Industrial Age
and so it's crucial to have a larger
vision and you know part of the how we
wind up with certain sort of regressive
political movements at the moment in
many democracies is because we've left
this vacuum where for a decade or more
we've been saying look a little tweak of
the interest rate here and a little bit
of retraining over there and everything
will be good and where most people sit
that's just not true
most people saying that you keep saying
that but it's just not working right and
so we we need to paint a broader picture
of a future and Susan mentioned the
spark of Hudson earlier that is also
part of that broader picture which is
who has access to knowledge how deep
bring knowledge to everybody including
people who've been excluded from it for
a long period of time
yeah so that's why we're working on the
Workforce Development Program we're
working on trying to get the
infrastructure in Hudson up to speed and
transportation so that people can
actually get to the work that that there
may exist so all the different parts and
and and also that the connectivity
infrastructure so people have high-speed
access and fundamentally changing you
know where and how you can learn right
so we have set up a system where the
presumption is that you need to go to
school in order to learn and then
ideally you go from school to some like
fancy college and if you don't do that
you somehow like not smart not worthy
can't learn things and we believe that
that's just not true that people can
learn things they can learn them at
different ages in different ways and
that you know a big thrust of digital
technology is to let people learn things
at any point you know including much
later in life now more than ever you
know your kids again are a bit older but
I was in parts of the country where they
don't have high-speed Internet and you
can imagine those kids now trying to
learn
mean there are so many kids that right
now are struggling academically because
of the fact that now I mean they've lost
months and we're looking at this fall
it's unclear what schools are gonna look
like but certainly having broadband
access to me is like a cornerstone in a
building block it's like how can you
make meaningful educational
opportunities available if someone like
that they're not even going to be able
to plug in in a real way so one thing
that you all have been very passionate
about which I think most everyone
listening this is going to agree with is
that so you know one cornerstone is
universal basic income and then climate
change is something else that you've
been very passionate about and working
on and so Susan I'd love to ask you
something that I just saw an article and
it made me almost jump for joy where
someone who's an environmental activist
said hey universal basic income might
really be part of the solution lighting
up our environmental footprint so can
you talk about the work you all have
been doing on climate change and how you
see some of these income policies
impacting our ability to make progress
on a sustainable economy all right well
this is well I can talk a little bit
about the fact that right now we're at
toiley farms and what we're doing here
is we've got a little expression call
we're growing climate solutions here and
the idea is to use this as an
experimental hub to address and test out
certain theories in order to capture
carbon dioxide and Albert you've been
running a number of the experiments that
have been going on here yeah so what
we're doing here is is trying to grow
additional biomass specifically with the
purpose of taking carbon out of the
atmosphere and putting it back into the
ground the relation to ubi is a really
interesting one first as we talked about
previously will let more people be
politically active and get to solutions
for the climate crisis but the second
thing is there's also some evidence
early evidence that ubi changes people's
view of consumption
and the way does that is that when you
are no longer in the scarcity mindset
that oh my god I can't afford anything
consumption actually starts to loom less
large and people's needs and and all the
sudden people go oh maybe I should learn
something instead or maybe I should put
some money aside or maybe I should
become engaged in something so there's a
lot of evidence that the sort of
scarcity mindset that is forced upon a
lot of people makes it very difficult to
think beyond consumption and to think
about such issues as the climate crisis
and so it'll be interesting to see I
don't know whether we'll see this here
in the Hudson up trial but that is an
important aspect of ubi
you earlier said that I was sort of
saying time is money um it's a it's it's
more attention rather than time so
attention is this you know what is it
that within the last day for example you
actually consciously applied yourself to
and so much of what we're applying
ourselves to unfortunately it's just you
know consumption and it's just making
enough money to keep consuming and so
disrupting that to pay the bills yeah
the bill to put food on the table right
yeah so disrupting that is a crucial
aspect and it is hard to see how we can
overcome the climate crisis without also
getting past the Industrial Age the two
are joined at the hip I made the same
argument on the trail one of my hopes
was that if you had the boot off of
people's throats where you got enough
money where you could meet your basic
needs I thought we'd have much more in
the way of Arts and creativity and folks
going to the woods and working on a
novel and whatnot and adopting more
minimalist type lifestyles because they
would have different goals for
themselves and different pursuits
instead of driving and commuting to
their cubicle and doing job X like you'd
have more people doing things that were
more organic and and worse
that now in the with Kovan right a lot
of people are now moving to the country
and we're seeing that they're not
consuming as much as they were that
they're going out in nature that they're
enjoying it that they're that they're
doing activities that as Albert Zetas
are not consumptive and there's a basic
income project in Germany that Susan
that I've been supporting for years that
has a lot of evidence to that same
effect where people really suddenly
decrease their cuz this is sometimes a
an objection that people bring up to ubi
they say people just gonna spend it on
more stuff but actually the evidence
goes the opposite direction that makes
me so glad because I was making that
argument on the trail probably best I
wasn't citing like some German data but
like that the thing I was suggesting was
like look if you can actually get the
boot off of people's throats they're
going to be much more energized around
making different types of choices and
also be more attentive to climate change
because right now if you're laboring
under this constant scarcity mindset and
someone says you need to worry about
climate change and you're like I'm
worried about next month's rent yeah you
know it's like like like like the earth
is absolutely big grand problem that's a
years away and then the human impulse is
to say a thought about it it's not that
big a deal anyway like this is like the
sort of defensive response so I said
that's what we have to change for people
well and also the thing that we're
working on here at the farm is of course
the innovations around carbon capture
but also we're trying to change the
mindset of how people view the climate
crisis that you know it could really be
when you when you work to be sustainable
it can really be something quite joyous
and so the kinds of work we're doing are
ones where where where where it's all
around sort of enjoying nature and
enjoying you know we've gotten sort of
an electric you know a TV instead of a
gas propelled one to toot around the
property or you know an electric bike
you know things that you know ordinarily
you know you know maybe are a little
well yeah I mean it's the idea that we
have the means to overcome this crisis
without somehow all you know going back
and instead of living in a hovel right
and being dour about it we're having fun
while we're doing it possible but like
it you you to seem like movie characters
where you're like we had the fire carbon
capture electric giving buddy to the
community to fun Universal basic income
for five years like the whole thing is
so I mean I think you called it the
utopic foundation I feel like it's yeah
I mean it's it's the Utopia foundation
spelled EU topia utopia with just a you
means technically nowhere and utopia
utopia means good place so it's it's all
an attempt to help make the world a
slightly better place utopia why would
you code that is that a real term it's
it's a real thing we're making it a real
thing yes we can christen it right now
we should be seeking utopia yeah if you
go to utopia foundation.org beginning
but the the fact that you were putting
it all in a practice in such a positive
way I think is so powerful you know like
that there's the abstract which you can
argue for it and then there's like and
look here's the practice here's us doing
it here's what it can be in in real life
I have not been to the farm yet but I
need to get there oh yeah you need to
visit yeah no absolutely and and you
know what the hope is that other folks
will look at what we're doing and try it
in their own communities you know
because we really want you know think
that what we're doing both and Hudson
and here in the farm you know we want
people all around the u.s. and the world
to you know start ubi projects to your
pilots and to you know experiment with
carbon because we need every you know in
carbon capture we need everyone to be
working on these different problems and
figure out in their own town how to do
it and so as part of that our plan is to
also open source everything we do at the
spark of Hudson and
of all the farms so that people can just
access the knowledge freely
yeah and we're creating a playbook for
the ubi pilot of which we're partnering
with you and you know with the idea that
you know let's all let's all figure this
out and try different kinds of pilots
and see what works oh you two are again
forces of progress really they make it
more evolved humans than most of us
so however I said time was the new
monies that attention is the new money I
feel like right now we're in like a
particular strange moment where so we're
all most of us are inside and so we're
engaged with various media offerings and
social media and there's like this right
now this moment around sort of the
drawbacks of social media to some extent
there's this Facebook boycott where
people are concerns like what is going
on on Facebook there's all the
electioneering obviously people are
thinking you know where are we going to
get political information to vote for
president this fall or the four other
elections so when you talk about like
attention as the new money like what can
that look like if we do it right and
what can it look like if we do it not so
right yeah so I think of attention as
the new scarcity so capital was the
defining scarcity of the Industrial Age
land of the agrarian age food of the 4-h
now attention is the defining scarcity
you know you can't go back in your life
right you can't go back and change what
do you paid attention to yesterday I
wish we could I wouldn't have watched
that day well I mean that's the thing
you're right I mean and look you know a
student who is walks into an exam
ill-prepared can't go back and suddenly
prepare a nation that goes into a global
pandemic ill-prepared can't go back and
say oh we should have done more research
on coronaviruses
you just can't do it right so attention
is fundamentally scared and the business
model of some of the biggest
corporations is premised on hogging as
much of that attend
they can because advertising which is
the fundamental business model of
Facebook and Google is the resale of
attention it's taking as much attention
as you can get and then taking some of
it and selling it to the advertisers so
um their model tries to grab our
attention and not let go of it and
that's a lot easier to do by giving you
faux outrage by giving you cheap
emotional things as opposed to saying
hey why don't you go and actually read
this difficult book or why don't you go
and watch this hour-long video that
actually explains something in depth and
really watch it to the end and then
answer these you know that's not in the
interest in the interest this here's a
quick hit and here's another quick hit
and here's another quick hit Wow every
YouTube video has a quiz afterwards you
know in and so it's easy to like you
know YouTube combines in one place the
best and the worst of the Internet right
there are amazing videos on YouTube um
their channels like numberphile that you
know like make math come alive in
mathematicians own words it's absolutely
wonderful and it's free and it's
extraordinary there's incredible yoga
videos for free meditation stuff you
know and then of course there's also the
weirdest wackiest conspiracy stuff all
there and so or even darker like toxic
dangerous hateful ideology it's not even
weird it's like genuinely destructive in
cursive absolutely and so I think what
we need to do in order to um be in
charge of our attention is three things
we need to be economically free that's
the ubi portion we've talked about we
need to be informational e free which is
we need to be able to program these
systems right now we are being
programmed by these systems we need to
get to a place where we can program
these systems and then the third part is
um we need to be psychologically free
which is we need to each have some kind
of mindfulness practice that lets us
figure out when it's time to put the lid
down on the computer and walk away and
just you know rest with our own thoughts
for a while well let that mindfulness
practice is something I could not agree
more that we need more of and we should
be teaching it in schools we should be
promoting it throughout society now if
anyone wants to dig into Albert's
thoughts on this his book the world
after capital is available for free
online I believe it is yes
like Albert's not the type that was
hoarding info you just like put it out
there and people can access it freely
that is really according to what he's
saying like you're paying for it through
your attention like anybody put it there
so the fact that youyou you're
advocating mindfulness doesn't surprise
me that both of you seem very mindful
like you that when I talked about like
you being elevated people and would love
your advice and this is just me being
selfish now for the parents out there
really because this is such like an
incredibly stressful time so first have
your children been around during the
summer like they are a bit older but I
know school might be out for them yeah
so they've been they've been around
there they're a little older now so
actually they've been going in and out
of the protests that are happening in
New York
socially distancing hopefully definitely
wearing masks critical but you know I
think you know hopefully we've instilled
in them the importance of being
politically active and to participate in
you know in what's important in the
community and that black lives matter
movement certainly is is you know top of
mind and and critical so they've been
doing that and I think on the
mindfulness front completely agree with
what you said Andrew it's something that
ought to be taught in schools you know
it's it's something that it's like an
owner's manual to your brain it's like
the missing manual for your brain right
um but I think everybody needs to find
their own practice you know mindfulness
like can come in many different forms
for some people that's running for other
people that's yoga for other people it's
meditation it's breathing whatever it is
it's it I don't think there's sort of a
single prescriptive thing but talking
about it is already a good starting
point because I know the word sort of
been slung around so much that it people
sometimes roll their eyes at it but it's
actually really meaningful and and if I
think about if I could write myself a
letter to you know in my 18 or 20 year
old self that's the one thing I would
put in there it's like develop a
mindfulness practice it makes you a
better parent a better human being
soon as your children have any stories
from the protests I talked to someone
who attended and it seems like a very
different thing than what I seen on the
press like I don't know if they came
back and shared with you any stories
that made you either more or less
concerned for them frankly like
attending well it from what I understand
there's a real community that's being
that's being built so in addition
obviously to being present which is
there at down it they've been down at
City Hall our son for instance has
gotten involved there's a there's a
makeshift library there and so they're
there book groups that have been forming
that he's been involved in and
participating in so I think the idea
that not only are they obviously United
for a certain cause but there's a you
know there's a real community that's
being built among among the protesters
which is it which is lovely to see
hopefully not too close to one another
yeah well I saw some data points that
suggest that the protests have not led
to a spike in infection rates like you
you have the sense that people are being
pretty responsible at least that those
were the seen it also seems like most of
the really big transmission events
happen indoors so you know it might be
worth pointing out and I think you've
done that too in the past that you bi
one of the big supporters of course was
MLK and and I think in general there's
been you know support from the black
community from parts of the black
community for you bi as a way for people
to kind of be free from some of the
economic disadvantages that they've been
sort of systematically exposed to for a
long period of time serve reparation
that's happening yeah I made that case
all the time and I'm
to say I met with Martin Luther King the
third MLK his son who said that this is
exactly what his dad was talking about
when he was killed and the most striking
thing about this conversation was that
he referred to Martin Luther King as dad
because dad said that I'd be standing
but still just having him say that and
enter your son will be saying that about
you well one day is oh please my kids
were the least interested in my campaign
it only got good for them when I got a
bus so they were like that is a bus yeah
I think your exact words during the
debates were this is boring it looks
like Evelyn was trying to get them to
watch they're like look it's dad it's
dad actually just now literally two or
three days ago one of my son stumbled
onto a YouTube video about universal
basic income that then mentioned me and
I think that was the new high-water mark
for me as their father like cool dad is
that I was in a YouTube video that they
found by accident so that was a good dad
moment for me
[Music]
[Applause]
today's episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by athletic greens which
is the all-in-one daily drink to support
better health and peak performance so
even with the balanced diet as it's
difficult to cover all your nutritional
bases and so athletic greens is this
daily drink
it's like nutritional insurance for your
body delivered straight to your door
it's this funky green powder that's
pretty awesome you poured in some water
shake it up drink it tastes delicious
and it's got this complex blend about 75
vitamins minerals whole foods sourced
ingredients all this goodness to help
you get your veggies it's pretty great
if you're like me you do not have enough
veggies in your diet and then athletic
greens you like put it in a cup drink it
and you know you actually did what you
needed to do for that day if you're like
an efficiency fiend who I use they're
like oh I gotta get stuff done and this
makes you feel like you're getting stuff
done because you're being good to your
body it feels good yeah like you know
what's working you know you can tell
it's one of those things you drink in
you're like yeah this stuff is working
so whether you're looking to boost your
energy levels support your immune system
or address gut health now is the perfect
time to get athletic greens visit
athletic greens calm slash yang to claim
a special offer of 20 free daily travel
packs with your first purchase a $79
added value again that's athletic greens
dot-com slash yang its all-in-one
nutrition you drink it and it'll make
you feel better about yourself your day
and what you're doing long-term for your
health and the one thing I found out
that if you're doing like the keto thing
the Paleo or your vegan or dairy-free
your gluten free it checks all those
boxes it's pretty much everything free
you're good
that's Ledet greens.com slashing
[Applause]
well I'm so proud of your your boys uh
and for being part of history hopefully
we can get some real policy changes
across the finish line where black lives
matter is concerned yes and daughter Oh
your dreams we have three yes how was it
sure if she wasn't but yeah that you
know that's something that that it's
it's interesting where it seems like
there are all these things that are
aspiring together and someone called it
the Omni crisis where right now we have
the pandemic the economic displacement
and the job loss and then black lives
matter are all sort of tied together and
it's to me but something where it's not
like an either/or it's like we have to
do it all like just the way that you and
your family are pursuing it like we have
to address economic scarcity we need to
address climate change and as part of it
we need to bring people together and see
that we're all we're all the same really
and that dividing us and in this case
brutally victimizing people of color is
reprehensible in law and all of this is
wrapped up in us being stuck in the
industrial age and that and so what we
can't be doing is we can't be continuing
to pursue incrementalist solutions to
this problem um you know it's not gonna
be fixed by the Fed printing a bit more
money it's not gonna be fixed by you
know saying we're gonna get out of
carbon by 2050 we need to this is the
time for the kind of you know we're
going to the moon not because it's easy
this is the kind of time we should be
pursuing we should be pursuing let's get
to you know off fossil fuels by 2025 you
know it's like how can we radically
transform how we're living in
recognition of that there's a incredible
a beautiful future that's possible if we
just let go of some of the past
I'm more optimistic about the prospects
of universal basic income getting past
than I am and I've been at any point
really the problem is that it's taken
truly horrific circumstances for us to
get to a point where I feel like 74% of
Americans want direct cash relief and
that hope I believe that it's going to
become a centrist political stance well
yeah very quickly and so I agree with
you that like the time for baby steps is
long long past like we need to be
looking at great leaps forward in part
because the deficit is so great it's
like we've let it build up for so many
decades that in order to catch up we
would need to do very very dramatic
things very very differently I'm
optimistic that people's minds are being
open to those possibilities right now
again unfortunately because it's it's
like a disastrous time wearing the midst
of it very high cost but you know that
there's certainly the silver lining in
this current pandemic is that it is
getting people to reassess priorities at
a much more fundamental level than
anything we've seen before
in the last you know decade yeah I feel
that urgency too it's like a crisis is a
terrible thing to waste like we need to
take advantage of this time because if
we just let this time go and then we
just slumped back into something
resembling what we were I'm going to be
so angry disgusted frustrated like
humiliated for us like as a country like
we need to stay energized and actually
get some things across the finish line
and people are going to be looking to
you to Susan and Albert for inspiration
as to how we can actually build a better
future I do so people find energy young
inspirational I find Susan Danziger and
Albert Vanger inspirational I find them
inspirational partners I've met bet
their children and their children are
like what I want my children to grow up
like these like multi-dimensional warm
carrying humans were like really
and interested in certain things one of
them's like like like an incredible cook
and the fact that I know that is just
like I think you may have benefited
actually that's what direct experience
like that's not you say that's like me
freaking like you know trying to food
what's so funny is you know now now that
we're on the farm you know we're talking
about like who would be valuable to be
up here and I like forget the bankers
forget the lawyers forget the anonymous
economists like we need people who know
how to like you know work the
instruments you know work the farm like
things that are truly useful yes
doctors electrician cooks right
absolutely yeah yeah my cooks a chance
to be very high on our list at least so
you know quarantine crew well but yeah
when people find me inspirational I find
you too inspirational and I am thrilled
to work with you on Hudson up over the
next number of years like we're gonna
learn some incredible things we're gonna
change lives I mean like that's one of
the the greatest parts of the campaign
where when you can actually give someone
economic resources in a real way it's
like their their mind first like they
react so emotionally and then you can
see almost like their mind open in real
time where it's like like a cloud lifts
or a weight lifts and the fact that
we're going to do that for people and
hunts it and then other people are gonna
see that that's possible I'm just
grateful to you all for giving us this
opportunity we're super excited to be
partnering with humanity forward on this
ya know really appreciate the support
here and I know that people of Hudson
are excited to it saying when when you
know when can we start how can we apply
so they're all they're you know they're
very excited about the prospect and
we're excited to see where it leads and
hopefully it'll be a model for other
communities around the u.s. and world
yeah well we're going to be keeping up
with this trial every step of the way
we're gonna be beaming results out to
folks people are going to see who gets
chosen and yeah it's going to be a very
human story thrilled to have it unfolds
like before the word
really alongside you both okay excited
hudson up let's do it universal basic
income five years changing ready susan
dancer your albert very community
forward and and if anybody listening to
this wants to contribute to it by all
means we're happy to add more people to
the pilot so yeah and we'll like plug it
in and then you know you can change a
life as well it's gonna be a very very
glorious part of history really we're
gonna make some history together
absolutely and thanks to JJ as well
yesterday you should connect us oh yeah
yeah JJ soon he's a great guy I'm a big
JJ Trebek
[Music]